There are two fundamentally
different ways to create and
store images and this affects how
you deploy images responsibly.
Raster and vector.
Raster images, photographs and
other images represented as a grid
of individual dots of color.
Raster images might
come from a camera or
a scanner, or
be created with the HTML canvas element.
Vector images, images such as logos and
line art, which can be defined
as a set of curves, lines, shapes,
fill colors and gradients.
Vector images can be created with
programs like Adobe Illustrator or
Inkscape, or
from using a vector format such as SVG.
SVG makes it possible to include
responsive vector graphics in a web
page, and
we'll talk more about this format later.
The advantage of vector file formats
over raster file formats is that
the browser can render
a vector image at any size.
After all, vector formats describe
the geometry of the image.
How it's constructed from lines,
curves, and colors and
so on, not individual dots of color.
Let's see what happens
when we resize this page.
Now, that's an SVG image on
the right and a PNG on the left, and
you can see as the size increases, the
PNG is looking to start a little blurry,
whereas the SVG is perfect at any size.